[Music]
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blocked you are not
my first choice you were here at the
request of admiral kazansky aka iceman
he seems to think that you have
something left to offer the navy what
that is i can't imagine
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you i'm not gonna
make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
having any fun yet
[Music]
[Music]
you